uh let's i mean speaking of um
uh uk not even uk but speaking of people
from
out that way breaking [ __ ]
what what are we doing conor mcgregor oh
geez louise
speaking of people kicking the wrong way
yeah
bro undefeated
the undefeated ufc champion is leg
breaks
yeah i mean crazy end of that
fight i was really it was really like
disappointing as a as a viewer you know
yeah i mean yeah i get it he's injured
all the best speedy recovery everything
like that i'm saying as a person who
spent 60 70 bucks on the fight yeah
whatever
and just sitting there and it's like all
this pent up energy and
we're all sitting there like on the edge
of our seats i'm sitting there like
eight people we're all like oh my god
oh my god and then
no yep
so wow so
the last i had seen was he threw a front
kick
and dustin's elbow like comes down
so yeah so it wraps it i think yeah good
old joe
there's another video of him kicking the
back of
justin's legs and you kind of see his
ankle
kind of take like a weird ankle a weird
angle
sure um but it has to be that elbow
maybe i mean it's because he broke the
lower half of his tibia it wasn't even
the ankle
really yeah it was lower half of his leg
oh so that's got to be a
super long recovery maybe you know uh
chris weidman was
back up within like a couple weeks was
he no not a couple he was like a month
or something
wow so you know it's wild about that
whole situation there was like this
i don't know i guess special moment
because
uh weidman he actually
i think anderson called him like right
away after he broke his leg he's like
look i'm gonna tell you
you're gonna be back up and walking in
three weeks just
trust me and so wideman has a podcast
now and he does he had this little
moment with anderson where
he's just like dude it's been on my mind
for years that like i celebrated after
you broke your leg and he's like i just
need to like publicly say i'm sorry
and it was kind of crazy because
anderson just cuts him off he's like
he's like don't say sorry
he's like this is fighting yeah
you don't even think about this [ __ ]
when it happens
you could tell weidman was like really
broken up about it he's like no no no
i have to say sorry it's like i'm sorry
chris is like
or anderson's kind of like yeah whatever
but there will be no apologies in this
scenario
yeah because conor he looks sad bro
conor yeah he just looks frustrated he
looks like we looked
that's how i looked after her yeah i'm
sitting against the wall god why did i
pay 70 bucks for this
[ __ ] again again it keeps happening i
paid for these fights and that's right
nothing happened and that's your friend
that you invite to watch mma for the
third day yeah they're like what dude
what happened so what was going through
your mind
when the pay-per-view was totally wasted
[Laughter]
there was no check
[ __ ] yeah and i i wasn't even tapped
in on like
the i guess kill you and you know your
wife's on my dm
yes i i watched the presser on youtube
like the day before
and then realized oh like some serious
uh
animosity here from connor
he was basically like i'm gonna kill you
you're gonna die in the ring you're
gonna go out on a stretcher that's what
he said
and then connor exits the ring on a
stretcher i was as a first armored
brother
said they were like mystic mac he
predicted one thing yeah someone left on
a stretcher
it just sucks it was a really good fight
up until there too
he was gonna lose you think so a hundred
percent
yeah a hundred percent so that's kind of
a blessing then
yeah he was getting pieced up on the
ground is there going to be a rematch
you think
no it was he was taking those elbows to
the nose he was getting beat up
oh my god that looked what no
elena is a big fan of savagery
you know her thing is like he was all
right she's like
you could have did okay i mean he he
almost got him in like a choke
yeah i mean i i think dustin even said
like
there was a moment where he thought he
might have played himself because the
choke was pretty tight
so that part you know it's not like
conor wasn't all there but once the
elbow started coming down he just looked
sort of like you know i don't know i
could have seen it going back to that
place
and imagine his leg didn't fully break
but it wasn't fully right either
yeah the same thing would have happened
his mobility would have been killed and
blah blah blah blah i just think he
looks sad because like
his legs busted he's like sitting there
talking like a super villain
your wife's in my dms yeah baby come see
me adapter
you lost man
you lost you lost that they had it
scored ten eight
and then dustin thanks that kid with
leukemia and the yeah the crowd
yeah ah man
no that was a good thing for dustin to
do i'm saying sad for connor yeah he's
like justin's clearly like
a man yeah and i don't know
he just i i think that's a wrap
your wife is in my dms your wife
i love liberties
yeah bro i think it's a wrap for connor
yeah it's sad i want to see
another i want to see a rematch i would
watch the [ __ ] out of that i'll do it
i'll buy it again i [ __ ] it
i just feel like his body is not in it
anymore
fighting to me feels like this thing
where
it's so kind of unnatural right
like to to be
always ready for combat like i feel like
you put your body in a particular state
where it's like ready to do those things
and i this is like there's some
superstition [ __ ] but i feel
when you're in that mode like when you
eat like how your body absorbs the
nutrients and where it puts that stuff i
feel like it's just doing different
things because it
it's sort of trained like at any moment
you're gonna like scrap
and i feel with connor for the last few
years he's only ever done fight camps
for the purpose of
like getting a bag but outside of that
he's got like the yacht and the this and
then that so he's just like living his
life yeah
so i feel at these like intermediate
fight camps where for six months
he's smoking cigars and doing coke and
then
oh yeah i'm gonna train for this fight
versus like what dustin said he's like i
do this [ __ ] every day
yeah dustin does that every day yeah
there's just no way that you can compete
with that
yeah and i i feel like he's put enough
miles on him that
i don't know i just can't see it yeah i
cannot see it yeah
so we'll see you know maybe maybe he'll
come back prove me wrong
a lot of people are like i'll pay for
that [ __ ] again just to watch him break
his toe
yeah yeah no yeah stop doctor stoppage
looks at the toe oh he's just wiggling a
little weird now we're going to stop
fighting
no no
that's funny about that is that sort of
happen to jon jones
what willie oh gross doctor stoppage
yeah doctor stoppage
wait what no we just wet willied him we
gotta stop the fight sorry
no no dude it's gonna be a
it'll be a crazy sorry go ahead there's
gonna be like an eyelash
thing exactly
i scratched my cornea doctor stoppage
it's such a kick to the you know old
school mma
or like five six years ago you could
call some people up and be like yo man
i'm watching the ufc card tonight and
people will go i've never really watched
that you're like bro come over
and you know every fight it's gonna be
blood it's gonna be
savagery for hours you're like yeah now
you can't even
you can't even confidently invite people
over yeah cause it's yeah scratch cornea
you know someone breaks a tooth like
just like obscure [ __ ] someone someone
has a headache they have to stop
fighting yeah exactly
it's like well because he might have a
coma you know on early onset coma from
getting hit in the head so much it's
like
i thought this [ __ ] was like that's what
you signed up for isn't that part of it
you know that's what i was gonna say is
that like it's
unreal every week ufc gets bigger and
more star-studded and more on
everybody's story it's crazy i mean i'm
a testament to that i wasn't really that
into it
yeah and then we started talking about
it more and more and i started just
watching every single fight
i feel like that's the same with
everyone this is gonna be the biggest
sport in the [ __ ] world in like two
years
yeah everyone gives a [ __ ] about this
now it's
it's kind of wild because i felt that
ufc
viewership was going down and now like
yeah i think they've done a good job of
getting it you know uh popular again
probably because they got an elk in the
front row they got all those kids find
them i can't believe they just posted
that video today of
addison ray oh like saying hi to trump
because i guess there was some i guess
there was some
stuff about her when i her voter
registration came out or something like
that and she was registered as a
republican i guess like people gave her
a lot of heat for that
got it and then i guess she said no i'm
a democrat or something i don't know the
full story so don't quote me on this at
all sure i just literally read a tweet
like briefly right before we started
this
and then milk just like just shamelessly
posted that video for saying hi to trump
just and she's like hi hi i had to say
hi my name is addison just airing it out
yeah just airing out just throwing the
pot crazy
wow yeah the best part is this whole
tweet where she goes i studied
broadcast journalism for three months to
prepare for this moment
and her follow-up tweet is golden what
does it say
never mind y'all got me fired oh
night night is that real did she really
get a job for the which they no she
probably was just like you know just
like a guest
see the way i read that is she she
passed that
like uh stand up whatever it's called
what is it called steppen stepping
stubbing she passed the step and repeat
was like oh this would be a funny photo
oh and grabbed the mic and i have the
mic for a second and she took the photo
and then that was a joke because then
like i went to broadcast school for
three months just so i could take this
picture sure
that's how i read it yeah but i guess
people thought it was real
and they were like i don't know yeah
maybe it was real she got fired
yeah maybe she was just gonna you know
like fighters walking in like are you
excited for the fight tonight whatever
and yeah mr trump mr trump can i
i just had to say hi i just have to say
hi
it's pretty funny but yeah she got
canned
so overall i mean there was other some
other great moments on the card tai
tuivasa
knocking out greg hardy that was crazy
oh it wasn't the two heavyweights going
at it yeah that was pretty well you guys
like wobbled and then he hits him with
that
left yeah that guy was a football player
uh greg hardy yeah yeah
yeah he's got some controversies that
man does he yeah
like some domestic violence oh yeah jeez
it was really controversial
controversial when he got signed
because it was like shortly after that
um and i've
i've watched a lot of people go at greg
hardy and like no one's ever really
brought it to him like that and then
seeing greg hardy go down like that just
that that man bam bam has got a
rocket launcher in his left hand yeah
[ __ ] is crazy
dang and the sugar show or whatever
oh yeah yeah he fought too right yep
sean o'malley
isn't he kind of like bigger than that
fighting so early on in the card
um he's a good draw but i think
it was his opponent had dropped out so i
don't know maybe he was still scheduled
for that time
uh but it happens you know some some big
fighters they just fight a little bit
earlier
okay but yeah he uh he punched the [ __ ]
out that dude's head
yeah i know i saw some clips i was like
jesus christ
that dude no shout was like this guy's
got a headache we got in yeah
yeah but i said i understood in that
moment i was like
when people were like oh joe was like
you gotta let him finish you gotta
i'm like i don't know man 250 expensive
the later half of his life yeah at the
expense of him
you know being sane when he turns 40 we
should probably after he took like a one
two lean back five uppercut that was so
clean
uppercut was brutal he just his hands
came up
and he's and then you know
her dean stops and he's like what the
[ __ ] i was i was fine
i was like you're not fine what the [ __ ]
i was in i have a fast
pass
dog what you're not at disney world
right now
what the [ __ ] man i wanted a turkey leg
dude
what the [ __ ] is your problem i ordered
beans
they're like i wanted guac with those
chips
let me speak to your manager right now
i don't know if you know this man but
you're in a fight yeah so
you know i mean that guy's tough as [ __ ]
though yeah you gotta give it to him
man i hope his nose is okay
um speak and you know in the spirit of
competition i just have to say
your boy grew some pubic hair
dude thank you that actually brings us
to the sponsor of today's episode of the
lawn mower 4.0
[Laughter]
mascarpone manskabane mascapades
oh man that's that's gonna be actually
what we rebrand the podcast
manscapades the manscapade guys yeah
that's like when you go out
like you know night out with your boys
mm-hmm you know that's some manscapades
yeah
when you get some shots with your boys
hello admit cheering
chanting that's a big manscapade for
sure mm-hmm matching t-shirts matching
matching button-downs that's manscaped
yeah
bachelor parties mm-hmm slamming beers
manscapades what else uh
bowling you're bowling bowling is
bowling i love a good
mascarpaid knight playing pinballing
center
playing pinball yeah that's a manscapade
you